yeah the way the things are going the
Christians the church and like I'm
seeing some Churches even in UK they are
turned into buzs and the clubs and uh
you see some some Churches even Muslims
buy the land of the church and they make
it a mosque you're telling that you're
telling half of the story these same
churches who have sold their buildings
sold their buildings to get bigger
churches come on you have Asia over
there in China Christians converting by
the mass
over there in China in Africa in
Nigeria in eth you know Ethiopia is
already Christian and stuff like that
but you have different countries where
Christianity is having a mass surge of
growth you know in these non-american
countries be honest and you know be
consistent so I want you what you just
said now apply it to Christians we also
have the same filling actually a little
bit more for the companions of Jesus for
the disciples and the apostles okay
right for Paul for Peter Matthew and
them the Apostles of Jesus we believe
one they were they're in held in so high
esteem because they were inspired by the
Holy Spirit to carry on the words of
Jesus Jesus literally says that the holy
spirit will come upon you and he will
bring to your remembrance all that I
have told you
and guide you into all truth so there's
no way when they're conveying the
message of Jesus and writing it down
that they can make mistakes in conveying
the message same with Paul so we we
believe they had that Authority backed
up by God that they're protected from
that type of error and mistake are these
people are they chosen by by the Holy
Spirit or every Christian these these
particular people these apostles were
chosen by the Holy Spirit specifically
to carry on the message of Jesus and
you know uh help the birth of the church
as a whole do we have Apostles right now
no these were the apostles the apostles
were people who witnessed Jesus who went
and did Miracles you know all that kind
criteria that to be an apostle the the
Disciples of Jesus yeah so well you have
direct Disciples of Jesus yes the direct
Disciples of Jesus or also Apostles of
Jesus yes but also Paul who wasn't a
direct disciple of Jesus Jesus right
when he was here on Earth was but he was
also sent out by Jesus as an apostle
because he had a revelation from Jesus
and his Revelation was confirmed by the
other Apostles and disciples okay I
understand I understand your your point
of view yeah so this is why we're like
guys man there's no way Paul corrupted
the message of Jesus or Matthew or any
of them man they're they are Apostles
they are Guided by the holy spirit this
is what we believe this is why this is
why we hold them to such high because
they're handpicked by Jesus and the Holy
Spirit good so there's a question I
wanted to ask you I don't know the exact
verse I think it's John chapter I don't
know you know the where Jesus says when
I go the comforter will
come you know that ver the Muslim say it
is talking about Muhammad John 16 verse
7 yeah can you can you read for me that
verse so that I can ask you and learn I
got you I got you I got you John
16:7 all right so it says here
nevertheless I tell you the truth it is
to your advantage that I go away for if
I do not go away the comforter will not
come to you but if I go I will send him
to you there's a the one below now the
one that says it and when he
comes concerning sin and righteousness
and judgment
concerning which which verse is that
that's John 16 verse eight now so the
first one you wanted me to read was
verse seven yeah you got down okay there
this verse I think you can it's down
it's a bit down I know chapter 11 verse
11 or where he says when he he will
guide you into all truth he will glorify
me yeah that yeah yeah okay yeah so I I
still have many things to say to you but
you
cannot when the spirit of truth comes he
will guide you into all Truth for he
will not speak on his own authority but
whatever he hears he will speak and he
will declare to you the things that are
to come he will glorify me for he will
take what is mine and declare it to you
all that the father has is mine
therefore I said that he will take what
is mine and declare it to you so who is
he talking about right now then it's
Muhammad no it's talking about the Holy
Spirit the spirit of Truth the comforter
okay is the holy spirit is it like a man
or does he's a spirit he's the he's the
spirit he's the very spirit of God that
has a mind theh talking about the Holy
Ghost yeah that's the holy spirit so
does it have a agenda like the way you
say Jesus is a he yeah and the Holy
Spirit is given a masculine pronoun
called a he as you see here he he he
yeah and you know he has a mind he has a
will he has emotions he talks He
commands
he you know he appoints so good good so
he was saying he will tell you he will
tell you new things yeah so so from the
time when Jesus went up to now what are
the new things apart from Jesus message
that we know what are the new the Holy
Spirit us everything is in within
Jesus's message because the final
message is the gospel that's the final
message so what so what are the new
things he said he will he will right so
the new things are the things that Jesus
for for the sake of time did not expound
on so the Holy Spirit now came and gave
Revelation to the things that Jesus a
part of the Gospel didn't expound on so
like for example you have the entire
Book of Revelation that's an of a
revelation given to the Apostle John
right when Jesus was here on Earth John
didn't have that revelation of that go
of the Gospel he didn't have that
revelation after Jesus ascended you know
and a few years passed Jesus gives
Revelation right so
that's was was he a direct disciple John
yes yeah yeah okay I see I see so stuff
you have some things like that you have
some things like uh um you know where
they're breaking down the New Covenant
now that we're under the the law of
Faith now that we're under so Jesus
didn't to expound on that in detail but
we see that the apostles through the
wisdom of the Holy Spirit are are able
to expound on what that is on the New
Covenant and the law of faith and the
Commandments that we follow now you know
they're able to extensively talk about
that and go into detail on that okay
that's but now the Muslims the Muslim
Debaters they some some of them they use
this verse say it is talking about
Muhammad so how do you disprove it it's
not talking about Muhammad well yeah
it's it's absolutely silly so so so
let's go to verse S the first one I
quoted where he says nevertheless I tell
you the truth it is to your advantage
that I go away for if I do not go away
the comforter will not come to you now
the you who he's talking to do you know
who he's talking to specifically his
disciples
exactly you're right he's talking to his
disciples so this is where he's actually
talking to his disciples alone he's
speaking directly to his disciples okay
apart from the
so Jesus is talking to his disciples
saying that the comer is going to come
to you okay now obviously Muhammad never
came to the disciples right okay so that
puts Muhammad out of the question it
can't possibly be about Muhammad he
didn't come to the disciples that's
number one here's number two he goes on
to say but if I go I will send him to
you Jesus says the okay the comforter
yeah yeah so the comforter yeah the
spirit of Truth Now do you believe as
Muslims do you believe that Jesus is the
one who sent Muhammad no no you don't so
the person being sent here is sent by
Jesus so it can't be it can't be
Muhammad okay know so those are just two
of many thing reasons why this can't be
about Muhammad it's absolutely silly I
had a whole debate on it if you wanted
to check that out I have a debate on my
YouTube channel I debated a Muslim on
here on Tik Tok and you can watch it for
yourself bro it's called if you go on my
YouTube channel go in go to uh my videos
is called who is the Comforter um okay
yeah you you actually had like
a debate de on it yeah it was timed and
everything good good I'll check I'll
check it out really learn it's called
it's called who is the comforter mallah
so yeah but yeah I I don't want to
overflow you man you could you could
take thank you man I learn some new
things though and uh I just want to say
I don't we don't like dislike Paul it's
just a disagreement
you don't dislike Paul say you don't no
disagreement over like theological
interpretation does not necessarily
translate into personal dislike but it's
all right you know yeah it's all right
that's
that's yeah you we the same way I don't
dislike you I actually like you and your
efforts and the way you really work hard
and I was one time I told you I wish I
had you on our side let me tell you let
me tell you for every okay maybe you
said you have reverted some Muslims
yourself for every Muslim you have
reverted you could have reverted like
200 more Christians for every Muslim why
would I do that why would I guide them
to hell man that's what I'm telling you
that's what I'm telling you let me be
honest it's easier let me be honest with
each other okay it's easier to convince
a Christian to accept Islam as a way of
life because the
way yeah the way way the things are
going the Christians the church like I'm
seeing some Churches even in UK they are
turned into bus and clubs and uh you see
some some Churches even Muslims buy the
land of the church and they make it a
mosque you're telling you're telling
half of the story these same churches
who have sold their buildings sold their
buildings to get bigger churches come on
like no I think no we have to agree
right now the Christians they are losing
a grip of their religion they need to be
serious bro I I disagree they are that's
why that's why God logic you walking on
the streets
and not about Americans bro it's just
about Christianity period Christianity
is not an American religion it's just
Christianity you have Asia over there in
China Christians converting by the
masses over there in China and in Africa
in Nigeria uh in eth you know Ethiopia
is already Christian and stuff like that
but you have different countries where
Christianity is having a mass surge of
growth you know in these non-american
countries so you know you gotta you
gotta gota look into all of that man
look into the whole story man I see bre
I see bre you know I like you man you
can come up anytime thank you so much
I've been watching your lives though
I've been watching like for 20 minutes
sometimes and I see you are cooking yeah
the name the name now at this part of
the year is is Chef logic now man it's
Chef logic I I'll just stick with my
chef logic that's cool that works for me
you need to do I I like the videos you
are on the streets talking to the work
people the Liberals I really like those
videos I I think you need you need to
put more energy there and I I really
like the videos man it's amazing what
you're doing I agree with you I do need
to put more energy towards that as well
but that doesn't mean on the Muslims I'm
just no problem but you know I'm just
saying okay even though like you can
talk you can debate the Muslim but I
think like even you have to check like
your own people and first the people who
are trying the work people there are a
lot of work people liberal people ain't
my that's not my people why you keep
saying my people they ain't my people
I'm saying your people maybe is the
Christians who are the Christians before
and say now we are walk or they become
atheist they were never of us people by
they literally tell you that they grew
up in a Christian household they
themselves never believe okay yeah they
never my people man but they do need to
be reached you're right you're
absolutely right they need to be reached
you you should help me I need help help
me how do I help you how do I help you
man all right so this is the first thing
you do a do no no no no I'm trying to
help you help me man
Messiah how you say is Lord in
Arabic ruya what is it how you say it in
Arabic no no so
exit and
put don't say don't say it and the
Messiah there's no God God there's no
but God but God AB
father M rule
what's what's your Creed that's what we
say for you like God what do you say as
a Christian we believe in one God and
Father for from whom are all things and
one Lord Jesus Christ God of God okay
right and one Holy Spirit one Spirit
baptism Faith so that's the universal
thing you say you
know is universal something like that
okay kind of Butch it's about the you
know it's about the unity you know why
most like people with Islam are strong
with their beliefs mostly about the
unity the thing we say it's like we are
united unanimous you think that you guys
are united yeah I think you should you
should create something that like will
unite the Christians because I don't
think Christians are united the same way
Muslim
we are we are more united than Christian
than Muslim in belief I'm saying in
belief I'm not
saying yeah not physical Unity I'm
saying in belief I know we're talking
about belief yeah like you can go you
can maybe you can even accept from
someone have Creeds we have Creeds just
like you have a Creed or a shahada we
have Creeds we have Creeds as well okay
what so you are a Catholic no I'm not a
Catholic you don't have to be a Catholic
to affirm the the Creeds of the church
okay look for example let me uh I read
this out to you this is this is what I
believe okay is it that someone's here
saying Manchester is United too doesn't
mean they are winning we W the bro what
you saying so look this is what all
Christians believe we are united in this
this is the Nan Creed it says I believe
in one God the Father Almighty maker of
heaven and Earth of all things visible
and invisible I believe in one Lord
Jesus Christ the only begotten Son of
God born of the father before all
can you can you can you start it can you
start it I missed the first part right I
believe in one God the Father maker of
heaven and Earth of all things visible
and invisible I believe in one Lord
Jesus Christ the only begotten why why
you say Lord why not God it's a well can
you just wait till a distinction now
that's what the Trinity is there's a
distinction of persons can I can I
finish okay okay Finish finish sorry I
believe in one Lord Lord Jesus Christ
the only begotten Son of God born of the
father before all ages God from God
light from light true God from true God
begotten not made co- substantial with
the father through him all things were
made so through Jesus all things were
made True God a true God right begotten
not made right for us men
for us men and for our Salvation he came
down from heaven and by the Holy Spirit
was incarnate of the Virgin Mary and
became man for our sake he was crucified
under Pontius Pilate he suffered death
and was buried and rose again on third
day in accordance with the scriptures he
ascended into heaven and is seated at
the right hand of the father he will
come again in glory to judge the living
and the dead and his kingdom will have
no end I believe in the Holy Spirit the
Lord The Giver of Life who proceeds from
the father and the son who with the
father and the son is adored and
glorified who has spoken through the
prophets okay so that's the Nan Creed
Christians agree with that oh yeah it's
called Nan
Creed what is n is it is it a it was a
it was a n is like a a place a place
place you said they had a they had a
council they had a council of NAIA and
so after the council this is a they came
up with that this was the Creed oh I see
I see I see all of this stuff is in the
Bible all of this all yeah yeah I
figured I figured like there are some
verses there yeah well it's all good now
I've learned a new thing I've learned
your your Creed now when I say I'm Creed
absolutely absolutely so yeah take that
man come back next time we'll talk some
more man and uh see what hopefully you
help me in addressing those liberals and
help me bring them to Christ man need
100% I am a Muslim and I will bring the
Liberals to the Christianity way
first it's better for you like that's
crazy whatever they're doing right now
man whatever they're doing to the kids
and the schools is
crazy nice
we have a common ground with you you
have a common ground okay bro all right
brother you take care all right okay
peace peace